each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon it it is a great pleasure
for me to be here to introduce our 11th
President of India dr. Abdul Kalam I
also want to apologize that we were not
able to get a larger room for this so
thank you all very much for coming I
know many of you are watching online we
are streaming this live many of you are
outside in the lobby and we are trying
to get the lobby computer on so that you
can watch it there too there are some of
you are in the overflow rooms next door
so we really appreciate your coming here
this is my name is after bachi I'm the
Senior Director for community affairs
here at Microsoft many of you
participate in our Giving Campaign and
you continue to do so so thank you very
much this is a time of great need and we
do hope that you will continue to
participate in the matching gifts
program and the giving campaign we are
very fortunate to have dr. Kalam here
today dr. Bo Raghavan who is somewhere
in this audience he's right there is a
resident of Seattle and has been
instrumental in getting dr. Kalam to
visit us in Seattle many of us who live
here from the Indian American community
have actually funded a visiting
fellowship at the University of
Washington which allows us to bring
eminent Indians to Seattle and
Washington State to be with us for a few
days dr. Kalam is going to be here for
four days and is going to be
participating a number of different
events including one on Saturday
afternoon at the mo hi so many of you
who want to
and Hyrum should try and sign up for
that there is also a dinner that the
Indus entrepreneurs have organized on
Saturday evening and if you are
interested in joining us for that please
do so let me now introduce a individual
who really does not need any
introduction he is one of India's most
eminent scientists somebody who is
steeped in science and engineering who
came out of a middle-class beginning and
rose to one of the highest offices in
the country he was our 11th President
has been a foremost scientist for Israel
and has been part of our space research
including some of our major explorations
with Agni and other rockets that he
helped design but I think what you will
find that even though he is no longer
the president he continues to believe in
India's growth in India's communities
the underserved community and he is
working on some amazing concepts that
link both what he called soft sciences
and hard sciences soft sciences which
include ways to educate people and hard
sciences which are really engineering
and technology that can bring about
change and I hope that he will talk
about his new concept called pura which
is providing urban facilities in rural
areas so please join me in welcoming
president Abdul Kalam
I'll French my greetings to all of you
it's a fantastic experience to be in
Microsoft from yesterday I came to the
foundation and then I spent a lot of
time and today I was not in the show and
a lot of discussion research tea
discussions I had so I would have spent
the time there and they would have
forgotten what's going to I have to do
today so friends I am very happy to
interact with the Microsoft
professionals in the beautiful
environment you know before starting my
lecture which I have prepared I thought
of sharing you an experience the
experience something like this at that
time I was working very hard building a
missiles and everything was ready and we
were expecting a gyro component has to
come from outside and for the missile to
your accuracy thousands of kilometers
history traveled and ditched the target
then suddenly a denial came that gyro
will not be available for you
that's because of missile technology
control regime and nation said no we
won't give you the gyro the gyro has
needed accuracy point naught naught 1
degree per hour now what you do I have
to go to launch pad in a nine months
time so I had a big brainstorming
session like when I see a lot of young
fellows here lot of young people were
there in the brain brainstorming session
one our next clearly one guy got up he
said
mr. Kalam don't worry about the gyro I
have got a solution so we were all
wondered what what is the type of
solution he has got he told me the
software fellow there saying like
software people the solution he gave we
have gyro only thinking is not point
naught naught 1 degree per hour date
rate but we have gyro in our country it
gives a lower accuracy point not to one
degree but I will give you
yeah algorithm if you develop a software
only what you have to do is you sample
the error number of times instead of Y X
Y X Delta X time you sample give a
feedback signal to the control system
and so the control system continuously
correcting whenever the error when the
and the flight is advancing it will need
a continuous feedback so that the
correction takes place and there was a
tremendous criticisms and far and
against but I was convinced after few
hours of discussion I went I will go
ahead you go to the software
seven-member still they developed the
software code there are 15 software
packages in the missile system it is one
of them so finally when I was ready for
the flight there what accuracy we divide
their decided the impact point it has
improved much better the sieepiess much
better when the flight took place is the
fantastic success because of the CEP
error was almost to the target so I
believe many thing what we cannot do in
the hardware you can do it in software
that I have seen just now a you can come
in fewer demonstration the surface
computer so such thing possible so the
this experience gave me it how important
in the system development
that's why you need 70 to 80 percent the
electronics and
we're in a system like a launch vehicle
spacecraft and missile system so friends
I am very happy to interact with the
Microsoft professionals in this
beautiful environment beautiful
environment ignites the creativity of
the minds that's I have observed
creative minds lead to the innovation
the pioneering efforts of Microsoft
during the last 35 years with continuous
updates have injected new ways of
thinking in software design and the
evolution of application across the
world so all of you involved in that I
am very happy to be with a team which
can think different perform and do
business differently
yesterday I yesterday afternoon I wished
at the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and met the CEO Jeff and mr. William H
gates senior very interesting person we
had a good interaction with the entire
team I appreciate the work what they do
on global health global development
program and a unique program focusing on
the education that USA here comes an
interesting aspect at the end of the
discussion
senior gate presented me a book written
by him to be released next week the book
named showing up for life showing up of
life his own book with the three line
forward from Bill Gates his son now in
the foreword Bill Gates writes his son
writes dad the next time somebody asks
you if you're the real Bill Gates I hope
you say yes
I hope you tell them that you are all
the things the other wants tries to be
so it's a beautiful statement the that
one page forward only three lines are
there dad the next time somebody asks
you if you are the real Bill Gates I
hope you say yes I hope you tell them
that you are all the things the other
ones strives to be it's a beautiful
statement this good released next week I
understand one more code midnight I was
reading yesterday that book which I
liked from the book I quote senior Bill
Gates what he says in Vinod each one of
the chapters is his own words the others
world words people who often asked me
the difference between what my life was
like when I was a partner in a law firm
what my life is like as one of the
managers of large foundation yet for
diction the difference I noticed the
first was that whenever practiced law
people used to seek me out to get advice
to get advice
now people mostly want to give me advice
on how to spend my son and daughter lost
money
there's very interesting but anyway they
allowed me to talk to you these two
points because the book not had released
you I think it's a good one when I read
midnight I love myself when I see the
contribution of the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation to the world community
I am reminded of Bill Gates senior and
what a great father he is to produce
such a great son and we are proud of him
for the robust framework that he has
created with Microsoft senior Bill Gates
they remembered for two things that is a
response for bringing up great family
traits they embedded in his children
knowledge and philanthropy my greetings
to all of you friends you are working
their organization dear friends what
thoughts I can share with you today when
the software industry was doing well the
business was attracting the best talents
it was triggering enterpreneurship it
was spreading global the computer
courses were the best preferred choice
in engineering institutions suddenly the
economic turbulence I call it the
economic turbulence and the electron
turnover here is said I call it economic
thought but suddenly the economic
turbulence has caused a sense of
pessimism and the anxiety all over the
world
I am also discussing these aspects I
will be discussing how to come out of it
but I am confident that this crisis will
be over thought how do I get this
confidence based on my association with
the young professionals I am confident
that professionals like you can come out
with out-of-the-box ideas with this
context I was thinking what thought I
could share with you three three
perspectives based on my personal
experience have shaped my discussion
with you today the first one is my
continuous quest to find ideas instead
how ICT sector can contribute our vision
for economically developed India
by 2020 the development of 60,000
600,000 villages is a major part of the
mission for this vision through pure
providing urban amenities in the rural
areas secondly I am aware of the dreams
and the enthusiasm and concerns of my
country 540 million youth of India and
the aspiration of the global youth
particularly in the context of recent
economic turbulence thirdly I attended a
few weeks back recently a World Forum in
Dubai and Abu Dhabi which debated on the
topic Education Without Borders there in
addition to global experts about
thousand international students from 120
countries participated with a background
of all these and other inputs I have
selected the topic Microsoft and the
evolving Indian knowledge powerhouse in
my talk I'll be discussing the economic
turbulence situations in India you
inject economic turbulence situation in
India injected and possible solution
through three phase operation what are
the three phase operation one ICT enable
the Indian development to establishing
7,000 per US through physical electronic
knowledge thereby economic connectivity
by establish societal grid third one
rural business processing outsourcing as
a combination of development and
business invention and discoveries have
emanated from the creative minds as you
know that have been constantly working
and the imagining the outcome in the
mind I have seen this in India and
studied in many great institution in the
world with the imaging and constantly
effort all the forces of the universe
work for that inspired mind
thereby leading to invention our
discoveries in Microsoft I see in all of
you the results of innovation in
computer operating system office
software tools are for software
development
Microsoft has grown from Windows 3.1 to
Windows Vista and Windows Server 2008
and Windows like life towards network as
a platform I had a meeting with
Microsoft research team just a few
minutes before I have just now witnessed
the windows worldwide telescope and had
a walkthrough over the solar system and
had a demonstration of a surface
computing environment which is creating
a new dimension the Interop were
interoperable of only put in a computing
environment I greet all those who have
contributed for the vision to the
realization the vision of the founder
mr. Bill Gates has not only created a
brand for Microsoft but has transformed
the computing in the hands of educated
réalité to the common masses of the
world through the phenomenal growth of
ICT in the world history Microsoft has
created many unique pages which would be
accessed quite often by the posterity my
greetings and congratulations to all of
you for the singular contribution that
you are made in realizing the vision of
the folder friends I have been studying
with my software friends in India on the
four dimensions of Indian software
capacities capabilities they are the
International courier petition in
expertise and quality business sense we
have established in PPO and Surrey
sector
the evolution of enterpreneurship skills
and the establishment of software
capacities R&D like space difference
aircraft and the academic institutions
the next step is to achieve a nonlinear
growth
with the innovation Indian and iam
amongst Indiana Mansi IT industry now
recognize it's India's domestic consumer
market as a source of virtually
limitless economic power this will
enable the industry to build the
capacity for the kind of economic engine
a prodigious production and consumption
machine that can enable growth for years
to come
India is poised to nurture the
intrapreneurial gene to become a
competitive and global industry which
people's innovations and creatively
leading to nonlinear growth the
government and virtual capital system
are geared up to support the innovation
and creativity of the entrepreneurs
through investment to compete globally
this will make the enterprises to go
global when the world is globally
changing there's a paradigm shift from
the export driven market to investment
driven market definitely Microsoft can
be a partner today for example your
steal multinational company understand
that they can't make a steal in one
country and ship it out they look at
world resources and world markets they
build facilities and acquire companies
where those resources are markets exist
they make steel wherever they can enjoy
a competitive advantage another example
is in mobile communication where a
single chip is being designed in India
which brings down the size and increase
the performance of the mobile system the
request software is developed in India
in partnership with another country
manufactured in third country and
marketed globally in a single brand
hence global sourcing becomes the order
of the day for any innovative business
to grow based on the core competence of
partners and it becomes borderless when
Indian market is attracting the
multinationals
global powerhouses are lining up major
R&D investments in India which include
Intel Microsoft IBM Cisco asan 2007
Indian scientists and engineers will be
participating the global R&D which
results in global global brands in
product and system in global sourcing
environment hence Indian enterprises
well being the global competitors in the
global consumer marketplace for domestic
products will become a global corporate
errs in international market our lemon
plant clearly focuses on education with
an outlay of fifty five billion dollars
hence the invest in science and
technology and use our R&D for finding
solution in the global issues for value
addition in the knowledge economy for to
leapfrog into nonlinear growth our
innovations will will will will
technology enable knowledge enable
leading to value addition to the product
system and solution this will help to
scaling up for meeting the needs of
growing economy and propel the domestic
economy which will reduce the effects of
anticipated reduction in the export
ensure steady growth of the economy even
during the economic turbulence dear
friends with this ambience
I am visualizing how ICT professionals
including Microsoft can make a
difference to the billion people of
India in their transformation process of
course this new way of thinking may
become trendsetter for development and
business for the economically turbulent
world in many aspects let me now
describe to you my interaction with the
Indian IT community I presented to them
that distinctive profile of India by
2020 and saw their contribution to make
it to happen
the distinctive profile includes among
others reduction rural urban divide ye
cutable distribution and adequate access
to energy
equality water agriculture industry and
service sector working together in
Symphony availability of best of health
care to all the transparent IDI
governance how IT and knowledge
industries can be partners with the
Indian R&D institution and industries to
achieve the distinct profit of India we
have the mission of transforming India
into a developed nation we have
identified five areas where India has
core competence for integrated action
agriculture and food processing
education and healthcare infrastructure
reliable and quality electrical power
information communication technology and
self-reliance and critical technologies
these five areas are closely
interrelated and if progressed in a
coordinate way will lead to food
economic and national security he should
be remembered that 70% of Indian people
that is nearly 700 million people live
in 600,000 villages and the economic
solution to India will be indeed a
trendsetter to multiple developing
nations as far as rural urban divide is
concerned ICT can revolutionize in
outreaching the electronic connectivity
and knowledge connectivity the infamous
information system in villages can be
modernized training can be
cost-effective and rural PP o--'s can
bring about a paradigm shift which I
will separately discuss the areas in
which the ICT can help our assessment of
water availability and distribution
mapping the water bodies with GPS and
GIS and feedback system on availability
of quality seeds and fertilizers dynamic
market information cultivation timings
related to the answer
of monsoon and training in Buda critical
practice it for agriculture community in
a similar way ICT can find an innovation
innovative solution contribution in
every aspect of development profile as a
leading software company you could
consider Microsoft can consider how you
can become a partner of Indian software
groups in contributing to the
development profile of India I was
asking myself what type of innovation is
needed to enrich the Indian economy and
the other world economic which are
presently in turbulence
I had discussion on this subject with my
experts during my teaching assignment
and I am Indian stead of Management
Ahmedabad it came to light that the
Indian economy will be less affected due
to the world financial crisis the three
aspect the number one the liberalisation
process in India which started 1991 has
it checks and balances consistent with
the unique social requirements of the
country the second one the Indian
banking system has always been
conservative which has prevented the
crisis now third one the Indian psyche
is generally savings oriented these
three castles three these three courses
have reduced the effect of global
turbulence in Indian economy however
there will be a reduction in export and
reduction in outsourcing because of
global situation the drop in annual
growth rate of GDP could be around two
to three percent and still India will
get will gave at 7 percent GDP growth
these that time we need innovation in
our thinking to regenerate the
agriculture sector particularly through
value addition and the small medium and
small scale industries enterprises for
making higher levels of contribution to
the GDP simultaneously be out to enhance
the rural and urban infrastructure
particularly through the establishment
of 7,000 Purab complex pure means
providing urban amenities the rural area
complexes spirit of different parts of
the country covering about 600,000
villages the mission of pure is the
employment generation with value-added
skills through connectivities
connectivity with the icd and knowledge
connectivity with the dynamic tools of
India's predicted growth India is
spearheading the connectivity mission
the core of this connectivity model for
electronic connectivity for Prosperity
of 1 billion people is the partnership
between the government and multiple
institution in the public and private
domains the strength of this partnership
or collaborative growth and the economic
prosperity is facilitated by free flow
of knowledge and information in a
seamless manner cutting across levels
and boundaries embracing all walks of
life in the three sectors of the economy
such as the agriculture manufacturing
and services in this model for grids
bring about the interface of three
sectors of economy namely knowledge grid
in the figure of you can see health grid
ye governance grid and the Parag reader
let us look at the knowledge grid inter
connecting the universities with social
naam be a institution neurologically
socioeconomic institution industries and
R&D organization India is planning to
connect 5000 institutions across the
country with gigabit network for
collaborative knowledge sharing platform
the first phase implementation of
knowledge network has already been
launched recently how treating the
quality education to the new con Connor
of the country and the skill development
through tele education is major task
under this grid in
do if you take the healthcare grid the
interconnecting the healthcare
institution of government and corporate
and super specialty hospitals research
institution educational institutions and
ultimately Pharma R&D institution
India has already connect around 300
remote locations so far with more than
30 super specialty hospitals and
provides telemedicine a connectivity and
propose to implement the mobile medical
services in public-private partnership
if we go to e-governance grid inter
connecting the central government and
state government and district and block
level offices for g2g with government to
government g2c government to citizen
india's creating state wide area network
across the country India has the fiber
connectivity up to the block level and
what he needs to be lighted on we have a
National Yi governance program with 25
missions more projects in g2c domain
that government to citizen domain we
also need to implement g2g services
government to govern services across the
governmental units also many Indian
states are the process of establishing
state by the area network by 2 0 1 2 it
may be in operational in all the states
computerization of over 15,000 district
and subordinate courts are required to
be completed other major areas of
activities for the IT industry are the
establishment of 100,000 village
knowledge centers for the government to
citizen service delivery in he
governance the education and health care
and other utility services by the
government and b2c services in the rural
urban areas the software hardware and
networking industry has to provide
solution for all the tasks within the
next three to five years and party
straight in the development
operationalization of national league
governance plan the establishment of
100,000 common service centers for GTC
connectivity is already in progress with
public and private partnership mode that
pure knowledge grid the connecting the
proneural nodal centers with village
knowledge centers and domain service
providers which will provide a feeder
service to agriculture sector non
farming sector since these the backbone
for rural development all other
gratefully infused the knowledge into
this grid for sustainable development
education health care and good
governance pure portal William power the
villages through still enablement and
knowledge enablement thereby creating
economic connectivity thereby creating
economic connectivity in the pure
cluster the ensuring sustainable
development progress is the nodal grid
for the other grants the integrated
village knowledge related knowledge
centers will act as an interconnected
delivery mechanism for telling education
telemedicine and eagerness services
apart from individual access by the
people within and between the village
Nordegren village knowledge centers
through the pure greater reach grid is a
system of multiple portals the aim is to
maximize gross domestic production and
productivity of the land and people
through maximizing the performance of
each sector and synthesized by the
system of inter and intra sectoral
electronic connectivity to serve 1
billion people this will bring
prosperity to 700 million people in the
rural areas and 300 million plus people
that many areas apart from the
government initiative there are plenty
of opportunities available for the
public-private partnership and CSAR
initiatives of the industry not as a
charity but with the business
proposition
certainly ICT industry like Microsoft
and the foundation like Bill Gates
Foundation has a vital role to play in
consolidating CSR initiative as a model
project for India in a big way and that
will create a viable impact in uplifting
the Society for providing quality
education quality health care and
improvement in the overall quality life
of the people in a remarkable way
certainly India will extend all the
support in this direction in realizing
the vision of developed India before the
year 2020 and bringing sustainable rural
transformation through implementation of
Pro recently friends on 4th April 2009 I
launched a rural people rural PPO in the
hub and Krishna very distinct amoled
southern part of India the object of the
rural people Habad to establish the
rural people in all the districts of
southern part of India this hub will
train make the rural youth a employable
you infuse confidence in them and
transform them in line with the other
international PP workforce this has
prevented migration of the youth to the
cities from that area and promoted
reverse migration with the national and
state level plans of 4ye governance
rural people could become a value-added
employment opportunity for the rural
youth and take care of the e governance
activities of each district apart from
serving the international clients they
are also doing international people work
from a rural area and are you able to
compete with other counterparts working
in metropolitan cities I have suggested
replication of this model in many parts
of the states and country for serving
the governance needs of the country now
I would like to share with you finally
how Microsoft in Indian Enterprise can
work together on a specific mission who
will which will result in knowledge
products that will capture the world
market
I call it world knowledge platform with
the Indian experience of successful
international cooperative ventures from
concept to realization and marketing
such as BrahMos is a missile and
pan-african in network india is in the
mission of establishing the world
knowledge platform this will bring
together the world knowledge platform
will bring together the core competence
of multiple nations and India in a
science and technology leading to the
development of unique system for global
applications world knowledge platform
will enable join design development cost
effective production and marketing of
the knowledge products systems and
services in various domains based on the
core competency of partner nation to the
international market world knowledge
platform is a meeting place for science
and technology industry management and
marketing this world platform will
provide an opportunity for IT software
industry transformed from day from the
transform from present day system
powerhouse to knowledge system
powerhouse now to convergence of bio
nano and IT is expected touching every
area of concern to the humanity the
world knowledge platform will take up
the mission in some other areas
discussed in further which are of utmost
intensity to all of us to make our world
year safe sustainable peaceful and
prosperous place to live out of water
energy healthcare agriculture ICT
automotive and transportation habitat
disaster prediction aerospace and
capacity-building these are the area I
would like to focus only on certain
important mission which are relevant to
you one is health care the second one
knowledge products knowledge and third
one capacity-building like quality human
resource development for all the above
areas
the finally in conclusion friends
Microsoft and the Indian industry have
an established business relationship I
have touched upon the IT and knowledge
industrial requirement has a socio
business challenges recurring
cost-effective viable solution with wide
application to 1/6 of the world
population I believe that the innovative
creation of a new markets for
development of rural India will promote
new demands in other parts of the world
will have a large scale export potential
India will certainly explore the
opportunity worked with Microsoft in ICT
missions linked to development year 2020
particularly poor emissions I greet the
Microsoft professionals leaders and
microstrip on this occasion from here
and various locations my best wishes to
all the participants success in their
mission of promoting development through
software and services may God bless your
friends
thank you very much we'd have some
questions I believe that there are some
mics in the room you can give one more
Mike yes right yes professor kilometer
distinct honor to see you here and share
you know learn about your vision as
always I'm on the advisory board of
company that's near and dear to you the
it's a telemedicine company that works
has got about 150 hospitals in India and
also with your Panamera a pan-african
initiative they are now expanding into
Africa so are you doing well I'm there
they're doing well but telemedicine has
you very well know is a good idea
people have to figure out how to make
money out of it the interesting thing
about the telemedicine is since you
asked me is it's going to come in to
developed countries from developing
countries and I think in the United
States the we have a payee problem the
technology was invented here but I think
it's going to explode in countries like
India and then come back to the United
States because of the satellite
infrastructure that you create so what's
your suggestion no my my question really
was you have created the vision for
India and you have also you know a
platform to promote it President Obama
has now achieved technology officer
think about your talk here would it be
interesting for India to adopt a chief
technology officer as a cabinet post
moving forward anyway your suggestion
see actually what happened the develop
the the mission calls for five years
i'ma will be developed agriculture food
processing there's one cabinet minister
full-time there and then information the
healthcare and the education to
ministers full-time and then near
information communication technology
one full ministry then infrastructure
development we need for that she
exclusively would were not two cabinet
ministers then self-reliance in critical
technology these are the five areas are
similar to progress so I agree at one
aspect then mission mode operation that
is there should be a what we need now
then before 2024 to finish it then yeah
mission mode your board should be
established and then it
thank you dr. Kalam for spending your
value valuable time with us in Microsoft
you mentioned about the super speciality
hospitals being built in India now is
they have already right so can you
explain how and you mentioned that the
ICT can help improve and grow some of
these hospitals in the rate at which
they are being built in India can you
provide us some insight and your vision
in to have you believe the ICT can
actually help expand some of these super
specialty hospital programs being in
India see for example we are even there
is one active program in India you have
53 countries of Africa being connected
telemedicine tell you equation and
connectivity but is the heads of 53
countries the India is a major
development partner and there we have
taken about 15 hospitals in the various
capitals of African countries similarly
15 hospitals from here in India we have
connected through you know both fibre
optics and satellite the rimmel link
into the last mile connectivity so these
started working similarly under Monica
bar our Islands have been connected so
on some of the big hospitals in
Hyderabad
and in Chennai connected and the data
database is something like this your
doctor at an Demonica bar will diagnose
there's a problem and then he all the
images in there in a week particular day
the both doctor conference takes place
in Chennai and
andaman and they communicate to each
other with the images of the database
and then the consultations pass through
between to the patient what should be
done and also sometimes your serious
case the patient's moved out it's an
honor listen doesn't need to talk thanks
to Microsoft for giving us the
opportunity truly once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity so my question is one of on
one of your core areas which is
education and I just want to start with
the quotation this is a quotation from a
television serial that ran here for
about five years it's by the fictional
character at the White House
communications director and it goes
education is the Silver Bullet it is
everything we don't need little changes
we need gigantic revolutionary changes
competition for the best teachers should
be fierce they should be getting
six-figure salaries schools should be
incredibly expensive for government are
absolutely free for its citizens just
like National Defense so just like we
have the last mile axis which is a
frustrating problem in broadband that is
this last mile access problem for
citizens near establish schools but in
India schools are expensive for its
citizens the concept of government
schools is something that we failed upon
several times how does this factor into
your vision 2020 to make basic education
beyond high school not just up to the
high school but beyond the high school
level available to its humorous 600000
in the education system throughout the
world primary secondary higher
these are the three types my concern
concentrate mostly primary education
because the primary education nearly 250
million children are there for up to age
forget educated and your creativity of
the children has to come out of the
younger age for that primary school has
to function so we are putting all our
effort how the best teachers we must
train them and pump in the primary
schools and also government has decided
yeah bill is coming up shortly we have
free and compulsory education up to age
fourteen this to solution is the most
important if base is good they will be
good I have a second question a more
selfish one at some point
would you be considering sign book
signing I have a copy of your book no
brother cherished person no problem that
is a simple problem dr. Kalam to repeat
for the other said it is amazing to
finally see you in person I never
thought I would actually be able to do
this I read a lot of your work and I
know that you're a big supporter of free
and open source software now frankly
well Microsoft Chief was in DI top
divorces yes I remember yes sir I
remember that you mentioned that your
con isn't Bill Gates was interesting
due to this topic so one of the
challenges that Microsoft has in
interacting with Indian government is
frankly this ideological push towards
open source software so has your
thoughts on this change what's your
thoughts on the place of proprietary
software like Microsoft and free and
open source software see you don't need
to worry reason 3 the name
if you take your pieces today the world
you cause the PCs 93% of the PCs have
got window okay that's a situation now
but now you are going all out also to
the software giving the software making
it open source you should compete after
all is a competitive situations and
there if the people use are very
comfortable sometimes the open code
software the reason is they can play
around they can put their need so it
looks to me both will exist and the
finally Microsoft also will go for open
source already you're going through it
so it's an honor to interact with you
today I was really glad to hear you
start your speech with how an
environment a good environment is
important for igniting the mind and that
leads to other good things now as we
know that the global environment is
suffering in India many of our cities
are almost becoming unlivable because of
pollution neglect and so on I was hoping
to hear more about that it's part of
your vision for in 2020 vision for India
so my question is I didn't see it there
but I would like to hear your thoughts
on how important is environmental
environmental protection for India I
know that we have big other big problems
to solve but is this something we can
really ignore if or what are you d
I mean what type of work you do I have a
corporate strategy manager at Microsoft
you know you go to my website wwlp.com
there your click for the energy
independence energy independence you
will get an answer okay it is it is
something like this what I have
suggested and they given American
president also discussed when he visited
India last time it is like this is a you
here thought it is going to be
translated into action it is a three
dimensional approach number one
that type of fuel we use the drive the
car you drive here the car we drive in
New Delhi and they taught you anywhere
all at about 30 billion tons of carbon
dioxide okay every year these comes from
the fossil fuel we get the fossil fuel
with the high cost and also you get the
environment damage also get for a
release of a carbon dioxide so I have
suggested you should come up energy
independence means how you come out of
fossil fuel I have suggested three
dimensional approach only solar power
solar power you should use now solar
cell efficiency fifteen to twenty
percent now then carbon nanotube
technology has come in combination
carbon nanotube and a polymer you can in
great the efficient sixty percent some
of your laboratory a research
institution I mean in the university in
USA and India is doing that in three to
five years time our solar cell
efficiency going to increase to 50 to 60
percent then in that situation we should
go for solar power number number two
India is going for thorium-based nuclear
reactor because we have got abundant
thorium it will be thorium-based nuclear
reactor third is biofuel for all costs
will be driven by cars and trucks will
be doing biofuel and ethanol and
biodiesel okay these are three routes if
you go then a safe planet yet you will
have okay think yourself or buying being
with us today most of what you shared is
completely new to me so thanks so much
and it's a great vision one of the basic
question which are similar to what I
didn't see in the presentation is your
vision about how all of this could
eliminate the basic problem of poverty
and hunger in India because you know as
I said many of the newspapers even
locally in India or even the films
that's taken about India and whatever
news we hear on the Internet is all
highlighting the poverty and hunger
right and not about all the advanced
mint but so this is a great presentation
I really really appreciate it
I want to understand from your vision
how any of this I think education is
going to help help improving healthcare
is going to help but I am NOT able to
still connect how all all of this is
able to solve the fundamental problem
that we have which is honey water and
what many what you are do you know I'm a
senior auditor in at Michael Sarita very
good now it is like this is a good
question the vision India 2020 vision
what is the purpose purpose is 220
million people who are below the poverty
line how to live them up that means
dirty English the GDP 10 percent seven
percent now how to increase the GDP 10
percent and then I have shown the five
areas five years interconnect in the
five areas and throg that is poor
operating urban amenities rural area
there is a cluster of villages we use a
physical connectivity electronic
connectivity and knowledge connectivity
so that the economic connectivity will
come
you should remember with our
independence we got about 60 years back
okay so we are progressing definitely by
another 11 years time this fear remove
that there twenty to twenty percent the
people who were poverty line then the
economic prosperity will come in India
will become a developed nation okay that
is the that is the purpose of this
representation and also you can read a
book India 2020 a book which they're
transforming India into a developed
nation that also use a lot of details
okay and just a follow-up question on
this presentation which is what what's
your confidence level given the current
political situation in India right so
turbulent governments you know corrupt
in all states and said you know I had a
I had a professor I had a professor his
name is Satish Dhawan so he gave me a
big project that is to build a satellite
launch way
and to put the royally satellite in the
arbitrator he gave all the money all the
money all the human power required in
seven years time you put the satellite
in the orbit II told me everything else
do you
I found the job was too big because
there's a lot of senior people who were
there lot of young people how do you
bring them all together I was hesitating
then he gave me an advice then the
answer for your question
advice is if you don't do anything no
problem you agree if you don't do
anything no problem but if you do a
complex program of a national
development there will be problems but
problems should not become your captain
he addressed me you should become the
captain of the problem defeat the
problem and succeed okay we understand
and we have time for two more questions
so please be very brief great to see you
here dr. Kalam yes I just have a very
simple question actually there's a
education problem in the United States
that says basically schools don't
deliver the kids don't learn anything
and India we have a different problem
that it's not a problem I'll say we are
producing properties more engineers in
India than anywhere in the world but
still what would it take for I would say
a kid who's growing up in India today to
get very enthusiastic and remove all the
public apathy that he's been seeing what
would it take see I a fantastic question
you asked it is something like this we
have India today there are quite money
okay and we have a required resources we
have thereby the material resources
water and the everything we have and we
have 540 million youth the most powerful
resource on the earth above the earth
under the earth okay
okay then what'd he say a missing lot of
young people I meet here very month
about 100,000 young fellows I tell them
if you want 20 20
some people ask me well why not before
2020 India become the developed nation
then I say I can do it confidence each
one of the youth if they build I can do
it then it becomes we can do it and
India can do it that one thing we are
pushing Eric wind Eric
very good day dr. Kalam you have been my
idol since I was like in school days so
I'm very nervous feeling very nervous
right now
Michel I read your book figures back so
basically two questions from that one is
how satisfied you are with the progress
that we are making as Conte a learning
with your vision
and second is the big challenge of
aligning both governmental agency as
well as like NGOs are learning with your
vision to kind of move towards 2020 how
do you like deal with that kind of
challenge see the one of the minimum
requirement is the GDP growth should be
where Mia and the document will say you
will read the document will say ten
percent GDP growth maintained for one
decade we you up to last year twenty all
right that if we reach nine percent we
thought 11 plan will do the 11 percent
and what happened is this economic
turbulence came in it is brought down to
the 7 percent but they still our pundits
the economic pundit says by September
will be out of the woods okay not other
words so I believe that to to 2020 the
target another 11 years India became
transforming developed nation we I am
still believe it is possible the only
one problem is the confidence that I can
do it problem should not defeat other
people probably would be all in a
democratic nation
with two billion people okay but now you
know 830 we have million people they are
going forward this month region 30
million people you know imagine they are
going for voting by electronic voting
they are going so in such a situation we
confidence that that what we have to
pump in in the the schools that youth
youth power should be a powerful force
say thanks a lot for being here you will
be a role model for many generations to
come my question is I saw everything on
your flights except execution of law and
order if I see exact execution of law
and order
I feel no matter how much of
infrastructure you provide no matter how
many facilities you provide until the
law is enforced properly and people are
taught to abide by the law nothing is
going to work so what do you have to say
I believe this area of law and order
very very certain problem certain areas
definitely the our judiciary one of the
best system we have in the country and
the another is crime deduction crime
deduction there are certain types of
crimes of increased definitely the
government as well as the private social
workers they are joining together to put
an end to this type of problems you know
we our population two billion people the
many problems come in definitely we can
defeat the problem okay take one last
question
no just do it one more only 1% we will
finish it off
I feel today like this my dream come to
like it's real like I never thought like
in my life like I could see like a
pilgrim so closely with my eyes and
really thanks for the Microsoft
organising such an event thank you sir
I know I question like um now in India
like the vision like the way we are like
a 20/20 like there's so many like
terrorist attacks they're happening like
a even across the india like are you
building anything in our vision like oh
- like how people should be aware like
oh we can now minimize those things I
have a proposed and they is followed
also what's called national campaign for
compacting the Terrorism national
campaign for combating terrorism it is
got three components the first component
she comes a unified intelligence system
unified for that government has already
passed a bill for a unified intelligence
system second thing is the type of
terrorists in any action any event takes
place immediately
we must take action finding and the
judiciary has to work very fast for that
exclusive self they have to form third
people should be P the partner people
should be the partner and it is very
important for that because when the
given Minds work together the good Minds
also to combine together to stop this a
mess okay so these are nationally apart
is we are pushing what why don't you get
us the next couple of questions together
and we can just have you answer so if
you can just ask
let us see how they are integrating the
questions thanks dr. Kalam I am aware
that the vision 2020 has been in force
since almost eight years and within that
period you have been a president I have
three questions first is that when you
are first is when you are a president
did you get the government of india to
commit you know to achieving this
mission and achieving the target and
whether the same thing continues second
is as a project where do you see the
status is it green orange red and going
forward you know and the last days what
are some of the actionable things for us
here in Microsoft that we can do to
contribute towards vision 2020 no no no
no no one thing I felt I don't know
whether he will cooperate with this
question or shall I finish up this
question number one the as for India
2020 I before become the president there
are two prime ministers I have to manage
two prime ministers warning one is watch
by G has announced in the parliament
that India 20 will be a national program
then when the the present Prime Minister
Manmohan Singh ji took over in
governance coughing he said he is going
to you committed to India 2020
government commitment is there now your
important question is what is the status
status I said just now that it was Java
so far it was green then suddenly it
becomes yellow because of the economic
turbulence but our economic experts say
Indian experts say that B will again
will pick up play occur the GDP to eight
to nine percent then the possibilities
by India 2020 still the eleven years are
the
with our youth power definitely we can
achieve okay next what do you think
Microsoft and what you want these well
no no I see I didn't answer that for
simple reason wherever you are wherever
you are working for a country for a
government for a country for an
institution you work for that country's
benefit you work for that country's the
progress and definitely your umbilical
connectivity is there your knowledge and
the experience you share but then you
should not wave on that that is you
should view as long as you are in
Microsoft Microsoft the US territory and
do you work for that country whichever
country you were you are there that is
my be okay next
thanks for the opportunity sir we know
agriculture is a backbone of India and
the problem I see in villages is
everyone is trying to study and then go
into jobs and some other jobs so they
are leaving agriculture part so the
problem is resourcing problem into
agricultural even my dad is into problem
because I am here okay so so how
technology can help directly agriculture
ectly into agriculture to prove
agriculture in India like go and pick
tomatoes and all that it is like it is
like this you would like to okay it is
like this you know we have in the poor
are poor awaiting urban amicus rural
area agriculture is one of the focus now
what happened is we are got 700 million
people working for agriculture no
country can will alow 70 percent that
people work in the agriculture by by
2020 2030 should come down to 30 percent
many of our farmers have to move to
service sector and the industrial sector
we ought retain them and put
them there meanwhile agriculture we need
by 2020 food from 200 million tonnes
they are producing now we need 380
million tonnes
that means we have to do the technology
only have to come on the great way and
also the multi cropping system the
farmers now we are addressing them go
for the jatropha cultivation biodiesel
consideration and in addition to the
normal agriculture they do and then they
should not stop the produce agriculture
produce they should do the value
addition marketing these are the two
solution we are pushing through Purim ok
hi dr. Kalam thank you for this
opportunity it's truly an honor given
that you've been part of the Indian
political system I wanted to ask you a
question related to a political reform
that we can bring about in India the
courrier the current political system
has this multi polity set up that really
does not promote national agendas but
MPs and MLAs or however they go they go
and try to to fight for political office
on the basis of very parochial interests
like I'll build a bridge for you but
there is no such form of like hey our
nation needs this I mean we have a
federal system but whenever we are
getting MPs elected to Parliament we are
really fighting on local agendas every
every seat has like 52 people there is
no real concept of hey this is what a
nation needs to be five years from now
ten years from now and that is why I
need to be part of the system no I am
going to do this for you guys and it's
very local and that's how political
offices are secured do you have any
ideas around whatever you are doing is
great at the grass yeah I have I have a
comment on what you what the concern you
what you are having it is something like
this you know the whenever or two things
happening in India law if you see the
lost the elections state elections a new
trend SW no in politics there are
two dimensions one is political politics
and of the development of politics
development politics means your party
which works for the economic development
of the state or a constituency you'd be
reelected so that started that is the
party which is contributing for the
economic development there's again again
three times they have elected two times
or three times they elected so that's a
good sign that is the unless you do the
economic development the your party
promotes economic development that party
will not get through this one mistake
people have given second message is the
multi-party system now I am a two-party
system for long basically forever
I put forth in the Parliament two-party
system very vital it may take some time
to mature for that but in a big economic
you Mary might not des I says he says
the economic we experts he says last ten
years India's growth pattern much higher
and compared to the previous years the
ten years of the multi-purpose party
system okay so if the different views
are going on but it's a fact but they're
finally to go for a two-party system
there's no doubt about it you find it
will happen in a decade strange will
happen okay friends all of you one
minute one minute one minute one minute
one minute one minute one minute I got a
mail from one of your Microsoft guys so
I have to give an answer for that mail
he told me last night to toe lock lock I
open I find a mail mail is how do you
good human beings beyond everywhere
India Indian young fellows yearn
American young fellows here how do you
become good human beings you know how do
you become a good human being will you
repeat with me what I say will you are
you are all hungry
will you repeat there there there is
righteousness in the heart there is
beauty in the character then there is
beauty in the character there is harmony
in the home harmony in the home when
there is harmony in the home there is
order in the nation then there is order
in the nation there is peace in the
world